Oh
Oh
this is muriwai beach in New Zealand
this is a sheep and this is Gandalf most
people come to New Zealand to check out
the country's unmatched beauty and to
get their middle-earth fix and that
makes perfect sense
but on this trip I'm hunting for
something else something less obvious
I'm after the innovations being brought
to life behind these doors in these
buildings and in this studio I'm heading
out on a 400 mile journey across New
Zealand's North Island from Auckland to
Wellington to find the most breathtaking
inventions these Kiwis have cooked up
you said it wasn't gonna be Friday this
is the first one that's going to go on
yep
the computer model has just become
conscious of something on this episode
of how the world will check out a mad
scientist some Rockets and an AI baby hi
baby
I'll either warm your heart or leave you
weeping over humanity's grim future
Silicon Valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them hello world
oh hello sky fellas
this is Auckland the home to 1.5 million
of New Zealand's 4.5 million people
people living outside of Oakland 10
Tanaka des congested and hectic
meanwhile people living in Auckland
celebrate the way of life it offers I
guess that a lot of place everybody's
going to go to
the city has a bustling food scene
there's a gorgeous harbour surrounded by
fertile volcanic land and those gannets
and black sand beaches you saw earlier
there just a half hour drive from
downtown this next parts gonna sound
cheesy but honest to god it's true
Auckland is full of cheery uptil mystic
people to feel good when you're here
like you can do stuff big stuff crazy
stuff like say replicating human
consciousness on the inside of a
computer face it's our primary means of
communication yeah but it's been
untapped in terms of a human-computer
interface here dr. Peter can express
itself to you in a human-like way which
is emotional that's cognitive no that's
when you start getting to this sort of
interesting place go on a CAI baby on a
sunny afternoon
the fellow you meet next is a madman in
the best possible way gonna pull the
muscles which basically lower the brow
he's Mike Sager a computer scientist at
the University of Auckland so nice rain
Clem would be yesterday's wanker and
she's noise up mark became famous for
building super detailed simulations of
the human body and ended up winning a
couple of Oscars for his work on films
like Avatar and King Kong sorry stay
here and these days
mark is how to put this trying to
reverse engineer the human brain he's
built a series of simulations around how
the human face moves how we express
emotion and how our neurons fire we're
trying to build a computer which has
experiences can imagine and basically it
has its own sort of existence in a way
so now what we're gonna do is I'm going
to run baby s what we're building here
is a computer that can learn so this is
baby please sort of looking at us and
hearing us if I make a loud noise and I
should get a fright this is what she can
see so you can see my face here a
through that eye so she's not copying my
smile she's responding to me and now
this is her little fist baby's fist
weird book so you can pick a bigger page
in a show or something but she has to be
looking at it's a get her attention
hi baby hi hi hi what do you see what's
this
puppy very good what's that baby this is
cuz we're New Zealand you gotta show
your shape yeah I'll give her the word
yeah yeah hi baby hi
what do you see baby sheep very good
baby the long-term goals is can we
create a computational model of
consciousness because then you get go
okay the computer model has just become
conscious of something is that thought
on now all the facial expressions
everything is driven by neural nets so
as we look around I'm going at his nails
remove her face basically and so this is
what's driving in the background and so
what you're looking at now these are all
the connections lighting out right as
the baby's doing stuff and this is like
a simulation of what would you have an
ingress in this brain yeah
because if you're going to make a
character biological and behave
naturally then you've got to use a
natural model so this is sort of what's
going on inside baby s now we take this
stuff and we a now connect it to
cognitive computing systems so you've
got biological neural networks connected
to artificial intelligence models and
the potential for that's enormous that's
where the future is probably going to be
there's a term New Zealanders have for
possessed inventor types like Mark
they're part of the country's number 8
wire culture like so many things here
the story of number 8 wire goes back to
those sheep farmers used to make their
fences out of eight wire gauge metal
then they started to use the wire to fix
just about any problem on the farm over
time a number 8 wire mythology evolved
to capture the can-do spirit of people
living in a remote place and other
people who had to solve problems in any
clever way they could but while New
Zealanders remain fond of the 8 wire
idea there's an undeniable sense that
the country is ready to level up it's
time to start inventing with more
purpose and polish the gritty garage
workshop is giving way to this a
pristine mad scientist's lab that looks
like it could be for sale in an Apple
Store sarey Avery embodies Kiwi
ingenuity he's a prolific scientist and
inventor sir Avery this is Ashley Vance
he made a fortune in the pharmaceutical
industry and then decided to dedicate
his life to helping the world's poorest
people
hence the sir all right this way so cool
house all right it's a to the magic
wardrobe
I followed sir Avery through a Wardrobe
door into his garage slash lab where he
creates his objects I knows everything
of the houses why did you're wearing
white yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm a bit
like Steve Jobs I have two dresses I
have black for winter and white for
summer the thing is that I know that
I've got 4,795 days left to live how do
you know that well because I've done the
algorithm analysis of somebody my age
born in my time how much Chardonnay are
drains all that sort of so I know what
I'm going to do with the next ten years
of my life failure is really just for
people are unprepared you don't waste
time on things that aren't going to get
you to where you need to go in things
like clothes
sir Avery is well known for taking
complicated medical devices and making
them simple cheap and durable did you
make this in here yeah yeah this is your
workshop lab okay currently he's working
on this incubator it really is a life
apart because it's almost like you know
something that Superman would be happy
to be in and the shape of it is really
much more about getting even air
distribution and trying to make it look
all the Life pod costs $2,000 versus
$40,000 for typical incubators the hope
is that it could save thousands of lives
each year I'll tell you this is really
cold this is oh my god okay so free
pretty pretty ugly he also has this
giant block of frozen chicken slurry as
a way to amplify the nutritional value
of trash meat that's after Kentucky
Fried have taken all their bits the legs
and the chest mate make it into this
stuff mmm
chicken slurry just have a spoonful that
later sir a remixes the trash meet with
of all things
Kiwi this breaks it down into the basic
amino acids so your body can absorb the
nutrients more easily it's aimed at
helping malnourished children if you
take that then you're going to get
instant energy you don't need to digest
it go straight across your gut this will
save millions and millions of kids lives
you know Einstein said the most elegant
solution is always the most simplest and
Kiwis have that a very practical way of
doing things if you take away the noise
that you have often with things like
Silicon Valley and just have a bunch of
guys in sheds for the lathe and a few
bits and pieces they come up with stuff
that nobody able to thought off
coming up we'll take a look at rockets
this is a dream come true I've always
wanted to be in the back then I cheap
that I'm hoping that I live after this
relaxing afternoon one of New Zealand's
most adventurous and affable inventors
is a Scottish import named Richard
little we know there's probably about
five million people around the world
that could benefit from using the rakes
he's one of two engineers who started
Rex bionics my best friend was diagnosed
with multiple sclerosis and like the
need to use a wheelchair in his future I
said why don't we build your robot legs
so we spend four years in the garage and
we actually got something working it
could sit in the could stand and it
could walk we knew then we would be able
to do this so the thing you'll notice
with the Rex of course right away is
itself support and it's the only device
of its kind like that because of that
most of the people who use Rex or spinal
cord injured although it can be any
mobility impairment if you stand in it
if you push the joystick forward and let
it go will take one step and stop if you
keep holding it forward I'll keep moving
forward okay what is the red button do
that's the emergency scale so if it all
turns the custard press the red button
okay so if you push it forward and let
it go that's it you're going to lean to
that site okay
well it's crazy I mean you really don't
have to put it Eddy you don't do
anything yeah
going to be Michael Jackson impression
this is Jared he lost the use of his
legs in a car accident ten years ago and
is now a wrecks employee customer and
test driver how long would you use it
each day use it for an hour day Oh give
me a couple of days paint relief off my
lovely
it's safe and it's general in general in
the skinners general in the bones when
you sit in a wheelchair all the time you
know you lose bone density
it causes skin issues bowel or bladder
and the act of walking helps resolve it
I've taken it home and walked into my
local bar because all I do you know walk
back in there for the first time ever
drink with my mates standing up around a
bar leader and to the people to borrow
what a trace yeah the day I was 17 you
later we raced up Mount Eden to catch
the sunset it's here on top of a volcano
that you reminded how young this
landscape and people are industry only
began here in earnest in the 1850s and
yet New Zealand has come an awfully long
way and the next stop for New Zealand
that would be space
I think New Zealanders don't think big
enough
they don't go after the really big
problems and the big billion-dollar
ideas I started building Rockets when I
was at school and the very first rocket
that I built I ended up putting on a
bicycle most rocket companies are
started by wealthy governments and
billionaires rocket lab was started in
2007 by this maniac Peter Beck
peter is one of the most capable people
on the planet he never went to college
opting instead to hone his own
engineering craft in the garage and
machine shops oh I don't know why
Rockets make me so happy now he wants to
make it much easier and cheaper to put
small satellites into space if you had
to set a lot on your lap right now in
one week I can have not an orbit
moreover I can have that on orbit an
order magnitude less cost than any other
way of getting it there the first rocket
launch will take place later this year
Wow
this is the first one that's gonna go up
yep
commercial customers have already signed
up and there's a two-year waiting list
how much are you gonna charge per flight
weight 4.9 million dollars okay
for point nine million dollars might
seem like a lot but it's actually a
remarkable figure and liftoff of the
Falcon 9 rocket and dragon the cheapest
way to get to space today is on one of
Elan musk Rockets from SpaceX and that
costs sixty million dollars per trip
propulsion performing amelie rocket labs
prices would open space to a whole new
set of customers including scientists
and businesses and in effect democratize
space this is what the aerospace world
has dreamed of for decades this is the
second stage second stage gym you can
lift it up yeah you rolled your eyes a
little bit of this eight wire thing why
is that if someone says you know rocket
lab is a number right water company
they'll get you sorted off the side just
gone because number a wire it's about
sort of bodging stuff together to make
network and it's really not what New
Zealanders have evolved to it's about
really high tech innovation and doing
really really clever things with large
day approaching the pressure is on today
they're running an engine test at a site
near the Auckland Airport so the worst
case scenario a blog hop blows up in the
best case is how does it deal or shut
down building a company is hot yeah
building a rocket company
damn near insane I hitched a ride with
Peter to the test site and arrived just
in time for countdown three
the engine test was successful but
there's still a ways to go what does it
feel like in your gut that countdown
clock in the office and everything that
comes with sleep much it's probably the
best answer to that question with a bit
of luck Peter will maintain his sanity
through 2017
that's when rocket lab plans to start
flying for paying customers this is a
tiny company of a hundred people that
will have bested entire nations and
firmly put New Zealand stamp on the
world that's not eight wire culture
that's just flat-out amazing and with
that it's now time to leave Auckland and
journey to middle-earth we could have
flown from Auckland Wellington and it
would have taken an hour but we wanted
to be basted in Hobbit vibes we had to
see the land
dear laptop
New Zealand is everything they said it
would be Plus burger O's smells like
meat
take slice or grind if aliens ever visit
earth and want to see what it has to
offer their first stop would have to be
New Zealand it's like a sampler platter
of landscapes rolling hills deserts
plains tropical forests whizzing by one
after another that's it for now thanks
for listening laptop love Ashley
three hours outside of Auckland we made
a pit stop in a hot spring all the times
leading into this place for you that
you'll get meningitis if you stick your
head under water I'm hoping that I live
after this relaxing afternoon
now before I learn about the meningitis
the more afraid I have that I have the
vagina you know you come to New Zealand
and it's all a wire cultures you can set
up Rockets XT you know dunk your head
underwater that you're dead so let's
employ [ __ ] is cool just reminds me of
love it living her out of my brain
coming up next on hello world action I
steal Peter Jackson's camera okay wait
you've got a run for safety and get
sucked into virtual reality
welcome to a rainy and famously windy
Wellington New Zealand's capital city
and home to a thriving film industry
director Peter Jackson is the local boy
made good he famously made Lord of the
Rings here and then shot past being a
one-hit wonder Peters created an entire
movie industry based around his film
production company Wetty
this is well II would it's just like
Hollywood but without any of the glitz
and glamour studio Lots and sound stages
are dull and unmarked they're tucked
into a quiet suburb called Miramar Wetty
has started to expand into virtual
reality and I was invited to take a look
at their first vr movie a scene from The
Hobbit where Smaug wakes up from a nap
you said it wasn't gonna be fried a
thief in the shadows
it's crazy bad I mean you feel like real
emotions what you see it that's the nice
thing moving Fuhrer you get the people
get such much more emotional experience
than seeing something like a videogame
or whatever I think that's kind of where
the space we're in the content
generation in the custom technology on
the software side to kind of enable
these these high-end experiences next
the studio where they filmed Lord of the
Rings I just want to grab that and have
a look around where I got a crash course
in motion capture filmmaking using Peter
Jackson's very own custom-made camera
which isn't really a camera but more of
a device to place a director in a
virtual world there's a screen on the
top that shows a rough version of the
final graphics while dozens of sensors
around the room record all of the
cameras movements all you've got to do
is yell action yep
they'll do this stuff and you say cut
like any other film actually get inside
hey good way you've got a run same thing
this tech brings a human element back to
green screen filmmaking it's more
tactile it makes the director actually
feel like he's shooting the film again
alright cut really good sport
when it became an industry of its own
and after the success of Lord of the
Rings spawned startups that are their
own mini wettest I'm actually on my last
stop I went to one of these startups 8i
studios
it's a VR company that is recording
people in three dimensions to bring them
into virtual reality the difference from
looking at a video to seeing a hologram
that looks just like the real thing is
so powerful a tie is developing software
that will bring VR to the masses the day
you can capture a loved one in virtual
space is almost here we'll show you some
experiences where we've captured some
humans with off-the-shelf cameras it
feels like you're in the room with a
person to check it out
sure alright so you can see the room yep
alright so oh hello
we create a virtual environment but then
we capture a very lifelike motion of the
cloth and the human performance and we
can compose those together so you'd been
a wet ever used to making these CGI
fantastic creatures but it just wouldn't
work for a normal person that happened
you don't want to drop a visual effects
Hollywood production budget just to
record your child experiencing the first
step right
and as we saw that these headsets were
coming along there was no clear
efficient cheap scalable solution to
capture reality and to author
experiences at a scale and a realism and
have a pace that would create a similar
sort of content database for people to
enjoy let's see how your fear of heights
is so this is gonna be like a movie oh
my god
that's crazy because I'm sort of like
afraid of heights
oh I mean I felt like I was gonna like
walk off a cliff
that was really Friday although I was a
bit skeptical it was time to scan myself
so I could meet the virtual Ashley which
way do I look like this way you have to
look anywhere okay you're captured from
from all sides so have fun and I just
have to stay in the circle pretty much I
was surrounded by 30 cameras all
perfectly spaced and measured it was
like in OCD paparazzi I'm Ashley Vance
except I'm not really Ashley Vance I'm a
digital asset that's being made at a
Thai studios and then in post they put
together all those different angles to
make a final 3d version of me if you
want to get really nerdy this is called
volumetric cinematography just for the
Nerds hands and pockets hands and
pockets it since my little virtual
friend so I get to see my virtual self
yes you've seen yourself many many times
in 2d video so I think I would be
underwhelmed I think I'm just gonna see
what I always look like in the mirror I
don't know why seeing like a 3d version
of yourself would be a big deal I would
much rather be chased by smog so I can
just walk around that yeah that's kind
of strange the details it's saying maybe
you can see like whiskers right yeah I
mean the cameras are just that good and
we're looking to increase that
resolution as well
Kira sausage step into yourself oh that
is crazy
well I also did not know where I was in
the roof so I thought it would be really
janky and I mean it is lifelike you know
and so that I guess was the biggest
surprise for me
so you think people are going to want VR
to be human I've got two boys and they
grew up so quick and it's like oh man if
you could just remember how they talked
and their gestures and the funny things
they said that would be really cool
here's the thing about New Zealand its
economy today depends on sheep cows and
tourists and everyone knows that needs
to change technology is the country's
future thanks to companies like rocket
lab Rex bionics and 8i the change is
already underway foreign investors have
started to pour money into New Zealand
and engineers are staying at home
because there are good jobs to be had if
you're an outsider looking to come here
well why not the scenery is breathtaking
the weather is good and the 8 wired days
have passed New Zealand is taking on
some of the hardest problems in the
industry it's working on the technology
of the absurd in the next episode of
hello world I go to Sweden and hang out
with moose hunters at the Arctic Circle
take over the country's electrical grid
seems incredible to raise the two people
would handle half a country's power and
eat cinnamon buttons with Spotify is
Daniel act like it seems more wholesome
than like a Cinnabon yeah